newly released text messages between
Peter Strock and Lisa page don't simply
have implications for the Russia
investigation they're also very
embarrassing for the FBI they tell us
more than maybe we wanted to know in one
text exchange Strock refers to the
Virginia citizens he serves as quote
ignorant hillbillies Hema spells the
word by the way
irony of ironies for the crime of not
electing Andrew McCabe's wife to the
Virginia legislature ignorant
Hillbillies the text also includes
Strachan pages shared post-election
meltdown Strock who is an adult male
message page in all caps OMG this is
effing terrifying he squealed Paige
replied oMG I am so depressed obviously
an articulate group a few days later
page wrote this I bought all the
president's men I figure I need to brush
up on Watergate the next day she added
God being here makes me angry lots of
highfalutin national security talk
meanwhile we have our task ahead of us
what our task was remains unclear mark
Klein is a Stein as an author and
columnist he's seen these texts and he
joins us tonight uneducated hillbillies
huh oMG Tucker I think I think last time
I with this came up on your show I
described these guys as like job Licari
rewritten by teen beat and I'm glad to
say they've managed to keep that up I
don't understand just to be serious for
a moment nobody ever resigns in
Washington unless they're caught up in
this me too business
so if Lisa page were to stand in front
of a camera and say that Peter struck
had conducted one meeting wearing Harvey
Weinstein's bathrobe he'd be out but
absent that nobody resigns I don't
understand why these two are still in
government service we were accused of
being bigots by Joy Reed and her chums
at MSNBC a week or two back these people
actually are bigots they they think of
verjus rooms as hillbillies they think
of
mein Ian's as sleazy one point they're
talking about this guy guseva the big
Internet guy in Romania who is described
as a sleazy romanian and lisa page he
texts struck back that all Romanians are
sleazy they combine the crookedness of
Russians with the entitled nurse of
Italian so what's that one two three
nation-states whose entire populations
have just been put down I mean that the
banality of this yeah I mean to go back
to what mr. biro your your previous
guests will say he does it oh they're
all sworn they've all taken this oath to
uphold the Constitution of the United
States well they're not they're just two
lovebirds who apparently get turned on
by the most bun by by hyper partisan
politics they are completely unqualified
for the jobs they are holding and why
they are still holding those jobs is a
complete disgrace to this FBI of which
mr. biro is so proud well because no one
has ever fired from the federal
government you're more likely to die in
the job than to be fired from a federal
job so maybe that's part of the problem
but you sort of sort of wonder like
what's the FBI response to this well the
FBI response has been to protect itself
you know this goes right back to when
the the Bureau of Investigation was set
up by 110 years ago in 1908 I think and
Congress was actually concerned so
concerned that the Attorney General then
bonaparte the guy who was Napoleon's
nephew or whatever he was Attorney
General Bonaparte specifically assured
Congress that the FBI would not be used
to monitor political dissent or to set
loose investigations on politicians at
the behest of part at their parties and
opponents in the White House well we're
seeing more and more clearly that that's
actually the to a hundred and ten years
later that's the two things the FBI is
doing they said their dogs on car the
page because they could get to their
political opponents they are monitored
they they they loose them on a whole
collection of Trump associates basically
at the direction of the most senior
figures in the Democratic Party this is
an absolute disgrace and those two
should not be in office couldn't agree
more
Mark Steyn thank you great to see it
thanks Doug